we all want what's best for kids but
when there's a disagreement about what
is best who should have the final say
parents or politicians it has the kind
of natural beauty the Golden State is
famous for but life here is calmer than
San Francisco to the north or Los
Angeles to the south with sunshine
surfing and safe streets california's
san luis obispo county is a good place
to grow up well i was 17 in high school
you know just about to graduate oh and
Beck play football and soccer for his
high school you know pretty pretty
oblivious to all the problems in the
world until it happens though I was
playing soccer and it was really hurting
one day when I was running so I just
kind of had to stop playing soccer got
went got an MRI it was just medium size
tumor just in the middle of my leg
doctors told Owen yet bone cancer I sure
crying um Owen parents Debbie and Steve
and then they said 20 doctors are goin
this is going to change your life
actually at the time I was just
concerned with you getting to the next
day the whole family's calm California
life stopped and the becks headed to
Stanford Medical Center I was worried
that he's gonna die 17 years old your
lives just stopped chemotherapy began
right away and the chemicals attacked
Owens hair follicles stomach cells and
mouth so I got bunch of mouth sores
which was very painful couldn't eat very
much and then it destroys your appetite
and then whatever you can't eat you
throw up
and for Owen the athlete yet another
blow doctors amputated his leg to try to
stop the cancer from spreading when I
woke up from surgery it was it kind of
felt like my leg was still there and
pull it all up and slide it right into
the sea life Owen was introduced to a
bizarre new agony called phantom pain
felt like someone had driven you know
thousands of nails into where my leg
would be for the first three months
after my surgery nod I would just lay
awake at night because I couldn't go to
sleep because I hurt so that all the
powerful medications available in
drugstores deemed worthless we had a
whole medicine cabinet in there full of
pills that he took every single day and
it did nothing Debbie and Steve search
for anything that would help howand feel
better one option however just wasn't on
the radar you know I don't think I did
with that in his in his situation
because of his age a new kind of drug
store had recently come to the nearby
city of Morro Bay it offered medical
marijuana state government allow us for
medical marijuana and local officials
welcomed the new dispensary and its
owner Charlie Lynch before we even open
I had the mayor and the City Council
members all came by and toured the
facility that's the mayor shaking
lynch's hand at the ribbon cutting
ceremony the new dispensary helped spark
discussion between Owen and his dad
houses talking one day with my dad we
just brought up the subject of it and it
was like that'll work that's what we do
the becks knew that many people think
it's inappropriate to give medical
marijuana to a minor in fact again and
again the local sheriff has made it
clear that he doesn't want medical
marijuana dispensaries in his County is
not in the best interest of a community
that prides itself in providing a
healthy family environment but the fex
weren't concerned with what other people
thought they were focused on helping
their son you're going to do what you
need to do to help your child
so the becks got a written dr.
recommendation and headed to Lynch's
dispensary since Owen was seventeen one
of his parents would have to purchase
the medical marijuana for him he came in
with his father he was looking really
thin and sickly that's definitely a sad
situation for you know for such a nice
guy several times we would go in it and
Charlie would say that you don't pay its
its we'll take care of it because he was
just kind of a good national power guy
the medical marijuana improved Owens
appetite it eased his pain and nausea
like nothing else had it was the
traditional meds that made him feel
stoned it would give me hardcore
painkillers you know they would just
make me dole out basically and fall
asleep and you know what the marijuana
you know I could I could do what I
needed to do during the day and does not
be in pain I could be comfortable Owens
experience is more than one person's
anecdote the medical benefits of
marijuana also known as cannabis are
well documented cannabis is amazingly
useful as a matter of fact is probably
too useful for its own good dr. David
Berman has spent about 40 years treating
patients and studying cannabis when you
see the list of things that cannabis can
help people say you're pulling my leg so
many prominent organizations look
favorably upon medical marijuana we know
that cannabis has medicinal value not
only from the 5,000 years of experience
but from hundreds of studies that have
been done at world-class institutions
around the world when Owen finally found
something that was calming it called the
whole family down
but not all was calm and San Luis Obispo
County this is Action News at eleven a
raid by armed federal agents local
medical marijuana users will have to go
elsewhere for the time being after
federal agents and sheriff's deputies
shut off their supply the Arroyo Grande
home of dispensary operator Charles
Lynch was also rated Thursday morning
they came in and threw me on the ground
and rushed through the house like I was
a criminal or something Lynch was cuffed
and brought to this Federal Detention
Center how did it happen the sheriff
invited the DEA to raid Lynch's home and
dispensary Charlie Lynch was an easy
target since medical marijuana is still
illegal under federal law and I have no
idea how is he I was going to get out of
jail my family posted four hundred
thousand dollar bail using their own
personal property eventually Lynch got
out but he was far from free for many
months he's been under various forms of
home detention they applied a electronic
monitoring system to my ankle the device
monitors Lynch's movements if he leaves
his house sometime other than during
designated hours federal agents will
know each day he spends two hours
charging the ankle monitor since the
charging cord is so short he rigged up
this extension cord to give himself
access to a little more of his home
without the extra slack Charlie Lynch
would be even be able to use the
restroom
we have a sick child we have a son
without a leg that medical marijuana
helps what is that they don't understand
about this we wanted to find out but
neither the sheriff nor the DEA would
agree to an interview the federal
government's official position is that
marijuana has no medical value there's
an enormous amount of politics that's
involved in drug policy and not nearly
enough science a pharmacist can fill
prescriptions for medical and feta means
without getting raided doctors can even
give patients medical cocaine but
medical marijuana well that's so
dangerous the DEA bust dispensaries with
armed agents the federal government is
the disgrace to science on this issue
today Owen uses this cool Robo leg to
get around he's going to college and his
cancer is in remission but the BEC still
can't believe that Charlie Lynch is
facing numerous federal charges in fact
because Lynch had clients like Owen who
are under age 21 he faces increased
penalties in California the average
sentence for first-degree murder is 20
years but if convicted on all counts
Charlie Lynch could face a sentence of
100 years in prison it's hard to imagine
you know that they they would want to do
that to me he's not a man you would
consider you someone who needs to spend
the rest of their life behind bars he
was just trying to help people he had a
prescription from a doctor at Stanford
and they took his stuff these guys don't
get it the DEA continues to raid
dispensaries all across California there
were 50 raids last year alone are we
really helping miners by keeping them
from medical marijuana at all costs or
are we treating their parents like
children
federal government is too big and too
bossy Charlie which is trial is set for
this summer jurors probably won't know
that state and local laws allowed Lynch
to run a dispensary and a federal case
all that matters is federal law for
reason about TV I'm true Carrie